Carissa you definitely took a very
aggressive stance out of the opening but
today it just wasn't meant to be you
didn't get your chances how are you
feeling right now um
appointed about the result but you know
I was black I didn't feel like I had any
opportunities anywhere and I definitely
made a few mistakes in the game so I
thought Kelsey played really well and
true I was a fair result do you know
Chelsea well you've had some experience
previous experience against her she's
from Massachusetts too so we grew up
going to like the same chess club and
everything excellent and how would you
characterize her as as a trustler since
you've played her quite a few times I'm
gonna be honest there was like because
Kelsey's a lot younger than me so
there's a bit of like lack of overlap
between our time at the club
so I have no idea but I think generally
she's a from when I saw of her games
When I Was preparing she seems to be
um sort of like not super aggressive
player I saw against the Sicilian lot
she plays like Kathleen kingside so I
was super surprised by the sort of like
Bishop G5 yeah
she's like the sharpest line against the
classical
followed by Queen D3 yeah
um I don't think I played this opening
quite right
I was definitely a bit
because I meant to surprise her at the
classical and she ended up surprising me
yeah
um yeah I don't think Queen C7 was right
but I was mostly trying to find a way
maybe get her out of the book and into a
position that I thought was comfortable
or more comfortable for me to play yeah
and you play Queen C7
um Bishop D7 and Castle really
aggressive played by you
but she tamed the position quite quickly
she was looking for simplifications as
well
take us through the game yes kind of
underestimate this bishop D3 move
um
I'm not sure why I missed it but I just
thought I would have like two Bishops as
you're ready to sort of sacrifice a Pawn
on F7 as well if need be
um
so what's happening if she takes I think
I was planning
um
what was I planning
honestly I think I was playing Bishop F6
Bishop to F6 here okay
okay which I guess after Bishop deep
three just kind of transposes don't take
the Rook
that would be a nice little checkmate
so Bishop D3 here
yeah and I guess
everything's liquefied in the center
yeah not a lot of pieces left yeah and
so
she definitely kept
her cool exchange the the pieces well
and it didn't feel like she gave you any
chances did you feel like maybe perhaps
once you got this King on D5 were you
hoping for anything at this point no I
saw I thought like when she got her King
out to D3 as well there wouldn't really
be anything and I totally just missed um
I saw where Bishop takes H6 idea that
happened later on the game
yeah and this was just
a gun game yeah want to make it work a
little bit for the draw you know you
were trying but yeah there's anything
yes absolutely and this tournament is
not decided in the first few rounds you
have so much experience we missed you
last year but you're back again take us
a bit about your preparation before this
event if any
um I didn't really prepare a ton before
this event I was playing two tournaments
sort of back to back in the last couple
weeks just because I haven't played
since January
um and I'm mostly trying to like just
shake some rest off
so
hopefully you know maybe I'm just
getting rid of some nerves here but I'm
just kind of looking to take a game by
game
Carissa thank you very much for uh
joining us and we'll see you in the rest
of your games thank you quick question
for you Carissa you and East Coast West
Coast you're now a Stanford uh tell us
what the West Coast experience is about
how are you enjoying Stanford
um yeah I Love College a lot it's been
my first year it's been done so that was
a lot of fun
um I will say I probably still prefer
the East Coast
sorry Austin it's just something about
it I like the cold weather when it's too
sunny it makes me uncomfortable you know
that's not right there should be seasons
all right well uh thank you Carissa it's
sunny more questions for you Carissa you
have experience with like playing the
the best tournaments here in St Louis
you played of course the U.S girls
junior the one that you played the boys
do juniors you played U.S Women's
Championship that's several Invitational
now how is it different for you to play
the US Women's Championship and the U.S
girls do you have a preference there is
in any tournaments you feel more
pressure or more enjoyment more friends
around
um I would say typically there's like a
lot of overlap between the fields of
like the junior girls and the US Women's
this year I guess all my friends have
gone a bit too old for the tournament
but typically you're getting old though
this is my last my last chance
um
but yeah mostly I would say I probably
prefer playing
um US Women's I like sort of like the 11
round structure I think it's nice to
have a bit of a longer tournament just
because you can sort of bounce back more
easily I think from any sort of loss
awesome thank you and good luck in the
rest of the tournament thank you
absolutely
and